[Music]
yeah i feel like
just going for the kill out of the
opening so let's go e4
oh scandy
okay scan me that's fine we
can live with the scandy
man man man
hey guys just doing a scandi speed run
team scandi guys let's just get flag on
move four
all right guys
yeah so we start with the move knight c3
now
i've
taught okay taught you i've shown a line
during the original speed run i don't
know if anybody remembers this line
there's a particular setup here that i
think is quite promising and incredibly
effective i think against players in
this rating range
i can see that people aren't really
remembering it which is okay oh no
not afraid 90 remembers it and that's
the move g3
now it looks pretty lame it's like
fianchettoing the bishop here might not
seem
like you know
this this isn't how you slay the medusa
but
it's actually you know if you give this
setup a chance you'll see that it can
get very dangerous for black
and there's a very specific idea that
this is associated with
which can be hard to face if black is
not accurate so we start by
fianchettoing the bishop okay we start
by fianchettoing the bishop
and
eventually black is going to play the
move c7 c6 which is very typical for the
scandi kind of creating
a little fold for the queen on c7
now the knight can go either to f3 or to
e2 it depends on how black plays i can't
tell you exactly where our knight on g1
is going to go which of these two
squares
our pawn is actually going to go on d3
which is rare for scandi setups
obviously most of the time you play d2d4
but this particular setup works best
with a more modest control over the
center of the move d3
and this is all leading up to a
particular idea which
i won't reveal just yet but
um
but i will
ultimately show you hopefully if this
happens
okay
i think this guy's asking me if this is
an official speeder on account i said
yes
okay he said i don't i said you'll get
refunded he said i don't care about the
rating okay anyways but it it says it
says in my notes that this is the
official speeder on account i'm not
trying to con anybody
okay so back to the game bishop g4
game abandoned okay where should we put
our knight
where should we put our knight
to me it makes a lot more sense to put
it on e2 actually
than on f3
the drawback of putting it on f3
is that you're blocking the bishop right
why did we fianchetto the bishop only to
sort of block it with a knight now there
are some positions where knight f3 is
good
but here i feel like 92 is more
congruent with
this setup to keep this bishop
firing on all cylinders
okay c6
now it's a great idea in such positions
to throw in the move h3
now h3 is kind of a no-brainer move that
you can throw in really without
calculating or without really knowing
what you're going to do next why is it a
good idea to throw it in because
it opens up the potential of going g4
out are we going to go g4 not yet we're
definitely not going to do it now we
don't want to weaken our king side like
this
but it's good to have that possibility
in case we need to unpin our knight on
short notice we have this in our pocket
okay so now we need to complete our
development right so we need to play d3
we need a castle it doesn't matter what
order we do that in we can castle first
we can castle first
then we can play d3
and then we will be essentially ready to
execute the main plan of the setup
so let's go d3 right open up our bishop
hopefully everything
we're doing so far is making sense okay
well this
actually not only does this still allow
us to carry out our plan but this makes
it five times stronger castling along in
these positions
is not dumb i mean it's an idea but it's
generally very very risky
now
it it also changes things a little bit
because
if black kid canceled kingside
those of you who've seen the setup
before will know that the idea i've been
hinting at is essentially just preparing
b4 b5 and creating pressure down the
long diagonal now of course b4 b5 is not
only the right idea but it's an idea
that could lead to a very quick
checkmate
and the question we should ask ourselves
is whether we can play the move b4
immediately do we even need to prepare
it because if black takes on b4
we open up the b file and the b file is
goes straight to black's king it goes
straight to the b7 pawn so to me
b4 is also almost a no-brainer i mean
worrying about queen takes b4 is foolish
so black immediately goes back to c7
thank you min for the raid
and now
we can continue attacking with b5
c5
now there are several
very interesting ideas
i think what most of you are probably
thinking about is like a4 a5 right a4 a5
and then b6
yeah and i like a4 i don't see anything
wrong with just pushing that that a pawn
up the board
okay b6 it creates a hook and
exacerbates the situation even further
what should we do now
should we still play a5 or should we do
something else
we should absolutely play a5 and i'll
talk a little bit about how i know that
these moves are good afterward i mean
how am i playing this automatically but
the bottom line is that we're trying to
open up the black king as much as
possible we're trying to create as many
weaknesses in the pawn structure around
black's king as we can which will make
it a lot easier once our pieces actually
get involved
now
should we take on b6 we don't have to
rush with that
we we certainly don't have to rush with
a takes b6 in fact i like the idea of
developing our bishop to f4 first
in order to
in order to connect the rooks
so let's start with bishop f4
and there's a funny trick here black
plays bishop d6 here which is very
which is very uh tempting and this is
exactly what happens we have a little
idea here so
what do we do and in what order well
there's two
uh actions that we can take and we need
to figure out the move right we can take
on b6 and we can take on d6 let's
compare so if we take on b6 black can
take with the knight
and then if we take on d6 black can take
the rope can keep the a7 pawn defended
doing things in the are the move order
makes a lot more sense because
after we take on b6 and on on d6 and on
b6
black is in huge trouble either he has
to open up
the a file for us which is deadly or
he would have had to take with the queen
which allows the move rook a1 to a6 and
then we double on the a file with queen
a1
hopefully that explanation makes sense
now we just take the pawn
and our queen is going to
join in the attack via a1 most likely
this is already devastating
totally devastating
okay
this is an instructive moment
who can suggest a
continuation here and there are
obviously multiple good moves here i
mean in such positions
there's usually two or three options but
there's one thing i like a lot more than
the other moves
so i think most of you guys are thinking
about queen a1 right which is
which makes sense but there's this
concept yasser introduced to me which is
can be stated as
uh the queen as the supporting actress
in in attacks that's how yasser refers
to it i wrote an article for chess.com
that's called that and what it basically
says is that people when they're
attacking have a tendency to involve the
queen first right you you use the queen
as the main attacker but that's actually
the opposite of what should be the queen
should be
you know the napoleon it should be the
war general
dictating things from behind
and the problem if you play queen a1 is
that black takes on a7
and then black moves the queen back to
c7 and do you see the problem we don't
want a queen trade and so your queen
actually becomes a liability if it's not
if it doesn't have a supporting cast we
need a supporting cast we need to keep
this rook alive and so we need to bring
it back to a6
not only do we keep it alive that rook
is also doing something it's pinning the
knight creating the threat of knight c3
to a4 which essentially just wins
material
the other very important rule to not
forget about when you're attacking is
don't just have a one-track mind and
focus on checkmate
winning material when you're attacking
is perfectly
uh satisfactory as well
so we want to be able to play queen a1
can we play queen a1 we absolutely can
but queen a1 might run into knight d5 to
b4
so knight b4 is is a pretty annoying
idea let's get rid of that knight
now are we ready to play queen a1
or should we throw something in first
are we ready to play queen a1 or do we
need to insert
something we're not ready to do it and
somebody thought to play g4 somebody
thought to play c4
sorry somebody thought to play h3
somebody thought to play h3 and this
comes in handy because now we unpin
ourselves at a moment's notice
the attack is coming from all sides
and
when you're attacking your opponent is
thinking it's a good idea to spend your
opponent's turn
coming up with general attacking ideas
like what are gonna be the next steps in
the attack
and the way that you do that is you
identify pieces that are not playing to
their full potential and you try to see
where how they can join the attack well
the queen can join the attack from a5
the knight for me two can jump to c3 i
love that move knight c3 let's play it
now queen as the supporting actress look
at where it's located it's on a1 what is
it doing it's supporting the knight it's
supporting the rook it's ready to jump
into a5 when necessary but we're not
rushing with that move we're using the
other pieces to clear
you know using using them as machetes to
sort of clear the path through the
forest and the queen will come in when
we're ready for it that's the sort of
philosophy behind that
yeah knight takes d5 is obviously the
threat
because we're pinning the knight on v6
that in fact black cannot defend against
that move
black is busted
forget about g7 who gives the who gives
about that pawn
yeah i mean black can play queen d8 all
yeah queen d8 is possible
but then we can already start thinking
about sacrifices like knight takes d5
anyway could be possible
we could also then play queen a5
i mean there's a gazillion possibilities
there
we could also oh i know what we'll do if
he plays queen d8 i know exactly what
we'll do and this is a move that
really
requires sort of advanced attacking
skills in order to be able to play
and yet i think if you understand the
concept anybody can play well obviously
now
we just play knight takes d5 we win a
bunch of material
and like i said now if there is a pawn
that you can take and it's not out of
your way
then by all means take that pawn right
it's not out of our way to take the d5
one does that make sense
why not
but g7 was out of our way that would
involve you know driving two hours out
of our way
uh you know
to some obscure burger joint
you know which has mediocre burgers
rather than just
you know
stopping by the freeway and taking d5
i don't know where that came from
what should we do now
what is the fastest path to victory here
and again don't look for hero plays
just look for checkmates and look for
the most straightforward continuation we
just take b6 what does that do
that allows the rook from a6 to move to
a8 driving the king up to c7
and guess what the final move of the
attack is it's a move of the queen
that's what i mean we didn't move the
queen from a1 this entire time
we're only going to do it when we're
ready
to do it
and i know this is not a particularly
special attack or anything
but
there are some instructive ideas that
remain behind the scenes
now but castling along there is just
this is a good example of what happens
when you castle long in these types of
positions
okay queen b6
maybe even the most resilient option
actually but it
we do the same thing
we take b6
now we give a check on a8
now we drop the queen back to a7 and we
win the rogue and we win the game
queen is a supporting actress
i have a good
similar game that i won many years ago
that proceeded in a kind of similar with
a similar arc
castling queenside is just very
dangerous in general like the vast
majority of the time in any position
you just got to be very careful when you
do that
okay so it's over
our opponent is still thinking but
we're expecting resignation
you get chills watching this live
yes
tillberg 1994 and now resignation
okay
so let's let's unpack
some of what happened in this game so
this setup with g3 if you check it on
the computer
you're not gonna find that the engine is
particularly
enthralled with this but
i it's brought me a lot of success
and it's brought students
a lot of success so bishop g2 bishop
bishop g4 is fine that's a completely
viable move
c6 h3 bishop h5 i still see a bunch of
games in the database
now the funny thing is i did miss an
opportunity here to play the immediate
b4
and by the way you can search skandy in
scandi speedrun and you'll find the
other game in this line
queen before the idea is rook b1 and you
win the pawn back with interest
ruining black's queen side
so
the immediate before was also possible i
see five games in the database queen c7
three of them continued rook b1 and
white is now ready to play b5
trying to open up the bishop and this is
this line at its best so just something
to file away into your mental directory
you don't always have to prepare b4 you
can play it immediately
and this is also true
of many openings right you don't
automatically always have to prepare
stuff sometimes you can remove the
middleman
so we canceled that's fine we went d3 i
still see two games in the database here
both of which continued e6
and now we would have played a3 now we
would have prepared b4
bishop e7
now
can we play b4 yet no we cannot because
b4 runs into
bishop takes b4 i hope everyone's aware
of this type of tactic
so in order to be able to play b4
we would have to develop our bishop we
can develop it to e3 for example
and roughly the line goes castles thank
you the mad king dress for the prime b4
and the point is like you push this pawn
down and b5 and this can get quite
unpleasant for black
because if black plays c5 it opens up
the diagonal for the bishop and we can
basically play
exactly the same way that we played in
the game
in the game black had the king on c8 but
this is still very strong even though
there's no king on the queen side the
idea of pushing the pawn up to a6
hopefully everybody can see that that
can get quite unpleasant for black
so
in this line white contends for a small
but stable
advantage and so i i really like it it's
very simple
and i wouldn't recommend just going out
and playing and i would recommend that
you do your own research
uh but but that you use these speedrun
games as kind of a basis if you need a
line against the scandi that's practical
and not very theoretical there are
several of those lines this is one of
them
so
castles right
and b4 to be completely honest is a
no-brainer i can give you at least two
or three examples from my
career where i did something very
similar and
usually you don't even calculate such
moves that carefully because
i think what a lot of people don't
understand is that
in the grand scheme of things in a
middle game sacrificing a pawn is not a
big deal period
it's it's only a big deal if you're
approaching the end game then it is a
big deal right if there is a risk of
simplification in a pawn end game being
down a pawn is often equivalent to just
losing on the spot but
in the middle game your risk is
essentially quite minimal
and and
you know here's one example of a game
where i i made a very similar move
taking you know only two or three
minutes just to check the basics but i
didn't really
you know put in too much thought
because because it really isn't that
much of a risk
yeah so this is a game that i played
against actually a pretty strong player
who very uncharacteristically made a
terrible mistake here so
black is already better i have the two
bishops
it's a nice position
but my opponent castled
queenside
and
well if you look at this from my a
technical point point of view you'll see
that white is attacking
the pawn on f5 right one two attackers
and one two defenders so e takes f5 is a
threat i think a lot of people would
automatically play f4 in this position
or or maybe f takes c4
but what did i play after about two or
three minutes of thought
and and this i'm not showing this to
show you that i'm such a remarkable
attacker this is actually just a very
typical attacking move yeah just go b5
and yeah my opponent oh well taking on
b5 is just immediately losing trade
trade and rook b8 and and white just
loses the game because you're gonna take
b2
after the bishop moves and if the bishop
doesn't move you're going to force it to
move with a6
so my opponent took on f5 yeah black is
upon down but but just look at this c4
a5
now i just moved my queen out of the
x-ray and now b4
i mean this is this is over right knight
b1 knight b5 sacrificing
another pawn on the c4 in order to open
up
uh
the c file in order to open up the c
file now i put a rook there
and my opponent resigned in this
position
i mean look at this is the final
position of the game
black is down two pawns
but knight b3 is coming followed by
queen takes b2 checkmate so
this is i'm less trying to
kind of explain the details of the
attack and more give you the bigger
picture of
the fact that moves like b5 should often
be played i don't advocate for anything
to be played automatically
but you're really not risking that much
when you sacrifice one pawn for a
clearly strong long-term attack that may
or may not work but you know for a fact
it'll bring you good practical chances
well
f4 and dark squares or the direct attack
how to decide well well that's what i'm
explaining right the direct attack to me
looks like a no brainer just because
what i'm seeing is that these pawns are
so overwhelming
the other observation is that white
doesn't have a dark squared bishop which
means anything that happens on the dark
squares is going to be devastating and a
lot of the attack basically proceeded on
the dark squares
so
you know if you just understand that
c4a5b4 is coming and there's nothing i
can do about it
then b5 becomes a lot more appealing
than f4
now
is there an algorithm for always
deciding this do you never save your
material obviously not but but if you
are an attacking player with the tagging
tendencies
the point i'm trying to make is that you
should usually err on the side
of of sacrificing stuff
as opposed to not sacrificing it
here's another example
just to hammer this point in where i
sacrificed two puns
and still neither of these sacrifices
you know i i didn't i wasn't too broken
up over either of the pawns that i
sacrificed in this game that i'm about
to display
um
because i understood that
even if a computer could defend the
long-term practical
potential was tremendous
okay so this was a king's indian game by
the way
world world youth under 14. um so this
was the samish i i played the classical
variation blah blah blah opposite side
castling as you can see
so the first moment
came after i played knight h5 and my
opponent played g4
what should black do
yeah so if if you go knight back to f6
you you'd get your your hands chopped
off in like a russian chess camp you
have to go knight f4 yeah this is just
this is a move you play with your eyes
closed and my opponent to my surprise
so he went knight g2 but and this is a
slightly trickier moment i was really
happy with what i did here
i was really happy with what i did here
i think a lot of people would say okay
well now
white is threatening
to
play knight takes f4 and the bishop
takes away and keep the dark squared
bishop so let's take the bishop but
that's not what i did or let's play g5
and support the knight which is bad
because it creates a hook that white can
attack it also creates a gaping hole on
f5
instead i just played knight d7 i just
decided to leave the knight on f4 my
opponent couldn't resist he took it
but look at what i get i get this
massive diagonal for the knight i get a
very nice perch for the other knight and
i'm just coming for him queen f6 b4
knight a4 just the potential is huge
queen f6
he took on c5 which was fundamentally
the wrong approach giving me a monopoly
over the dark squares
and now here comes the second sacrifice
after b4 knight b1
what
consequent sacrifice did i play
and this sacrifices upon two different
ways and yet i still didn't really
calculate this
just freaking do it just open up the
queen side boom
pawns are meant to be sacrificed and my
opponent couldn't resist he went g5
and then he took the second pawn
but now i start playing on the dark
squares right i build up a little
battery i'm threatening a pin but the
point is not to threaten the pin the
point is to prevent white from ever
pushing his center
and now i slowly accumulate or not so
slowly accumulate the pressure on the
queen side i push my pawn all the way to
a3
forcing b3 and now the devastating idea
who can find
the
crushing continuation of the attack
just understand how you want to arrange
your pieces yeah just bishop back to g7
queen e5
and i i did an attack in the best way i
decided to grab a pawn on g5 and it took
me a while before i was able to convert
um but i mean it was all very one-sided
i mean you can see where this is going
and i actually played a pretty nice
attacking i took another pawn now
material is equal i start pushing my my
king side pawns and you know
my opponent resisted for a while but
it was it was always
it was always over
yeah that was it was a pretty nice game
um
but it just illustrates once again that
in many cases these sacrifices are just
they're so one-sided that you really
should not
worry too much about them
okay so
back to the speedrun game
i i got fifth i think in in the under 14
or seventh and i did
decently
but i was almost the top seed
our opponent didn't even take before
had queen takes before occurred there is
one very important subtlety here
the tempting rook b1 is i believe a
mistake
why is it a mistake and some of you are
pointing it out
yeah so either queen takes c3 or even
bishop takes e2 same idea
and you i mean the the knight is
overloaded
and it's attacked so you have to take
the queen and black force is an end game
now white is still doing okay in the end
game you know white still has attacking
potential in the end game
but you definitely don't want to trade
queens if you can avoid it and so here
would be a very good uh spot to play g4
unpinning the knights after bishop g6
you can calmly play rook b1 and continue
attacking
um so our opponent didn't didn't go for
this line can't really blame him thank
you alfred not jagger queen c7 p5 and
now just a textbook right exactly what i
did in in my other game just shove this
pawn off the board in order to provoke
weaknesses
now i've talked about this before and i
won't delve into this right now too much
because this is something i could
deliver a whole lecture on
what are how are pawns used in attacks
because a lot of people when you hear
the word attack you often associate it
with h4g4 but what does that mean why do
we even push our pawns when we're
attacking
in my view there are two main purposes
of
pawns are used in two main ways when
you're attacking the first is
essentially to get rid of them
to sacrifice your pawns but not just
randomly in such a way as to create
uh entry points and files and squares
for your pieces so let me show both of
these uses here let's take a position
like this
situation one would be a move like b6
right blasting open this is what you
generally think of when you think of a
pawn storm you think of moves like these
what does b6 accomplish well it
accomplishes a few things first of all
it gives your knight the b5 square and
second of all it gives you a rook the a
file right so you've sacrificed the pawn
to create entry points
but the second way that you can use
pawns is to create anchor points for
your pieces here the puns participate
more directly in the attack and that
would be the move a6 which i think is
worse in this specific position but i'm
trying to illustrate the point
um and i did that in my the game that i
just showed right you're creating
potential entry points where now you can
put a queen there and you can use the
pawns to anchor your pieces in
so i could show you examples of both
types type one is much more common but
you can actually use pawns as attackers
themselves too you don't just have to
dispose of them
but if you're
orchestrating a pawn storm
you have to understand
whether that pawn storm is actually
necessary and it's not always necessary
to push
all of your pawns it's not always
necessary to play g4 h4 g5 h5
sometimes just pushing one pawn down the
board is good enough
and uh just to hammer this point home
i have one more
illustration that came to my mind this
is a game that eventually was lost
but nonetheless
so this is a game by todd of abrahamian
who perhaps some of you have heard of
she's a
good friend of mine and uh
obviously very strong player she's been
playing for a while
so this is a game from 2006
um us championship
and lev millman is now in finance but he
was very strong
almost became a gm when he was playing
so
in this position tatev she's white okay
this is a like super classic sicilian
position right and white plays it very
classically she plays g4
and black decides to castle into it
white castles into it classic opposite
side castling right
okay great
so i think a lot of people here
have this misconception where they would
just go like h4
and then g5 in no particular order but
the way tons of does it is nice she
starts with g5 because this is the move
with tempo so it makes sense to play it
first
now she does play h4
then she takes an opportunity to move
the king aside to b1
b4 millman is creating his own pawn
storm and now centralizing his knight
now f4
and after knight c4 queen moves up
millman goes a5 so both sides
are conducting a pawn storm
but here tata found a brilliant idea
this didn't work out in the game but it
i loved the idea itself
most people would go h5
with the idea of playing g6
the problem with this approach is that
even if you play these moves very
frequently
black can just sort of take and then go
i'm sure you've seen this kind of thing
before it can be very annoying to deal
with this because it's hard to make
progress
what does tantav do instead
how do you circumvent that
she plays g6 immediately
yeah and the point is that
here black just doesn't have time right
now
uh to do any of this fg you play h5
and now you don't have to play hd you
can actually shove this pawn down
potentially to h6
and now you force the h file open and
this gets incredibly dangerous for black
so this is just a much more efficient
way of attacking and if black takes a
tri well obviously we've accomplished
our goal of opening up both of these
files and now white gets huge attacking
chances
well if black plays h6 here
then uh you don't have to play hg right
you can play like queen g3 or rook g1
and and you can try to crash through
down the g file
so i haven't analyzed this deeply i
remembered this off the top of my head
because my coach showed it to me when
this game was played
so take this with a grain so i'm just
trying to illustrate a concept but the
concept is that you shouldn't just
blindly push pawns side by side with
each other you should understand what
your goal is
and your goal is often to open up as
many files as possible
okay uh after g5 can't black play knight
h5 blocking the puns yeah so knight h5
is a typical idea in such positions i'm
sure it's a move
but often what happens is that white
goes like bishop h3 bishop g4 and i can
show you other examples where this
knight on h5 often gets
uh in in into serious trouble with this
bishop h3 bishop g4 idea
and while you can go knight g3 and you
can eliminate the bishop look how many
moves you've made and you've actually
done white's bidding for her i mean
rooks on f1 and g1 are already nicely
positioned
so that was a good question but
uh hopefully that that makes some sense
but yeah in many cases you do want to
use your knight to blockade a pawn storm
and there's so many subtleties when it
comes to pawn storms and how to react to
them then i could talk about this for
hours but i hope that this was a
suitable
preface i just want to discuss one more
concept with respect to the speedrun
so we're gonna skip through
the next part of the game because we
played a5 everything that we did here
was incredibly
uh intuitive bishop f4
now we take on d6 versus then we take on
b6 right not the other way around
because a b there is knight b6 and then
black is able to take with a rook in
black holes on so we do it in the other
order takes takes
now if queen takes b6 then we have rook
a6 which is incredibly strong and then
queen a1 to follow
what if e5 after bishop before yes sorry
oh yeah that is the point i want to
mention
what what is the purpose of provoking e5
who can tell me what we gain from
provoking e5
and this illustrates the concept that
just because you're attacking doesn't
mean that positional considerations go
out of the window we gain the d5 square
now you might be like i understand that
but there's a knight on f6 who gives a
damn
well you actually can
uh earn domination of this square if you
look carefully let's say black plays
bishop b7 what tool is now at white's
disposal exactly you can play g4 and g5
before you know it there's a monster
sitting on d5 and the game is over black
is overwhelmed
so
when you're attacking you got to think
about first of all all parts of the
board right you can't just
hess likes to point this out you can't
just in your mind separate the board
into this
space
and this space and feel like they're
unrelated
stuff that's happening in the center
does have a bearing on what's happening
on the queen side
and yes of course black can play h6 here
but it's the fact that the square is a
long-term weakness that's black's
problem right black will never be able
to move this knight again
and you can play a move like f4
and try to get a knight tab force that
the other knight could go to d5 so
this just collapses for black so bishop
d6 we trade we take a7 now the game is
over
but yeah moves like rook a6 can can be
hard to play
um and hopefully my explanation was
suitable
um i want to show one more example of a
very similar move
which i played
years ago in a game
so i i had a very similar attack believe
it or not
very eerily similar
in 2005 so
a while ago
so here it is
last example i promise
okay
so
i was 1800
i had this position with an attack
and black's king is clearly exposed so
it's white to play
and well this was in my my mastering
positional chessbook so that's kind of
how i remembered it
what move seems to be topical here well
what needs to be considered for white
it's white to move
and what seems to be wrong with the move
rook takes a6 like if you're looking at
this move you need to have a response
ready
to
black's next move well knight c3 just
move your queen right knight takes e3 is
not dangerous
that's not
what's worrisome
well if you actually you have to pay
attention to like any standoff between
the queens this this is what you have to
notice and black plays c5
and it may seem very flimsy but in fact
white is losing the knight like you
cannot move the knight
or else you
lose your queen and get checkmated
um
so
what did i come up with here well it
occurred to me that i might want to
sacrifice that night but if you
sacrifice it
you've got to do something
uh why you know in the time that black
is taking the knight you have to set up
the attacks so now you go queen a1
which is what made me remember this game
and after c takes d4 this i think is the
important move
so a lot of people here
uh in this position would i think be
tempted by this check rook a8 check very
tempting king d7 queen a7 just like
streaming in
but again if you don't have a sense of
where you're going with it your the
attack is going to fizzle out black goes
back to e8 and white's lost a lot of the
advantage the king is a lot safer than
it is on c8
so using the concept of the queen as the
supporting actress and as the rook as
the main leader
you come up with a much better move that
i was really really proud of don't let
the king get out what should white do no
not bishop takes d4 you don't even need
that move
you set up essentially a meeting net
against the king
you play rook a7
yep and if black takes e3 there's mate
check
check and mate
so black was forced to drop the queen
back to c6 to cover the square and now
very calmly bishop takes d4 with
unstoppable threats against black's king
rookie five
rook a6 was a really nice move
forcing the queen back to b7
and now rookie a check and rook a7
skewering
uh pinning the queen there was nowhere
that black could have gone actually and
notice that this attack happens without
white's queen
making a single move until black gave up
his queen now it's the queen's turn to
rampage everything
so
yeah so so that concept i think is is
applied in this game as well but but
rook a7 you know these slow moves when
you're attacking can be hard to can be
hard to see
but it's not just always about
series of checks right you have to know
what what your end game is where you're
going with it
and often keeping the king contained can
be a better idea than just giving
meaningless and random checks
to the king
okay and with that
i think we can probably call it a day
that was a pretty deep
analysis hopefully you enjoyed that the
rest of the game after g4 knight c3 was
not particularly interesting it was just
totally crushing we just take d5 and
you know the rest was
the rest was uh history
so
thanks everybody thanks for hanging out
have a good
start to your week bye
[Music]
you